Autour du monde, des hommes
ont des bateaux comme maison.
Un mode de vie antique,
unique et de plus en plus rare.
Ce sont des peuples nomades de l'eau.
En Thaïlande, Ngui vit
avec ses proches sur un kabang,
une embarcation traditionnelle,
au mode de fabrication inchangé,
depuis des milliers d'années.
Au Cambodge, Mott et sa famille naviguent
sur leurs pirogues où ils travaillent,
cuisinent, dorment, sèment et prient.
Des histoires de nomades,
de voyages et de bateaux.
À la frontière du Myanmar,
ex-Birmanie et de la Thaïlande,
la mer d'Andaman est depuis plus
de 4000 ans le territoire des Moken.
Originaires du sud de la Chine, ces hommes
ont migré vers l'archipel des Mergui.
Plus de 800 îles disséminées sur 400 km
où ils peuvent pêcher et se déplacer.
Un vrai paradis sur terre,
pour cette tribu des mers.
- La mer, c'est pour nous,
c'est notre maison.
C'est grâce à elle qu'on
se procure notre nourriture.
C'est notre liberté.
Nguikatalé est un père de famille de 37 ans.
Ce matin, il fabrique une lance
qui sert à harponner les poissons.
Une méthode de pêche
traditionnelle pour ces moken,
dont le nom signifie immergé dans la mer.
Chez les Moken, on apprend à nager
et à plonger dès le plus jeune âge.
Ces hommes poissons sont
des plongeurs émérites.
Ils nagent en apnée de longues minutes,
et ils sont réputés pour leur
vision sous-marine exceptionnelle.
Il voit clair sous l'eau et
repère de loin la plus petite créature.
Quotidiennement, Ngui
entretient sa maison, son kabang.
- J'arrose le bateau pour
que le bois reste humide.
Je m'attends à ce que le vent se lève
bientôt pour qu'il assèche le bois.
Il devient alors moins perméable à l'eau.
Je veux éviter que de l'eau
s'infiltre dans la pirogue.
Entretenir le kabang, c'est comme
prendre soin des membres de sa famille.
Je le fais pour eux, pour qu'ils
s'y sentent bien et en sécurité.
Chez les Moken, on navigue en famille.
Sur le kabang de Ngui, ils sont 7.
Sa femme, son dernier-né d'à peine 52 jours,
une vieille tante et même 3 enfants
qui ne sont pas les siens.
Les Moken considèrent
qu'il est de leur devoir,
de s'occuper de tous les enfants de la tribu.
- Le père de la grande fille et
du garçon qui sont frère et sœur,
est mort d'une forte fièvre
pendant la saison des pluies.
La mère est décédée un an
plus tard de la même chose.
Ils n'ont pas eu le temps ni
les moyens d'aller voir un médecin.
- Je suis très heureux
de vivre sur le kabang,
parce que je peux sauter dans la
mer, m'y baigner quand je veux,
et dormir sur le bateau.
C'est vraiment très amusant.
- On ne se sent pas l'étroit du tout.
Plus il y a de monde, plus on se sent fort.
Le kabang est construit à partir d'un
seul tronc d'arbre et sans aucun clou.
Sans quille, l'embarcation est
légère et facilement manœuvrable.
Une petite merveille qui peut naviguer
en haute mer ou en eaux peu profondes.
Selon les Moken, le kabang
est quasiment insubmersible.
- Ce bateau est différent
des autres pirogues.
À l'avant et à l'arrière,
il y a cette échancrure si distinctive.
Elle nous permet de monter à bord
du bateau lorsqu'on est dans l'eau.
C'est très facile de grimper à bord
du Kabang, même lorsqu'on est en haute mer.
Dans l'après-midi, le vent se lève.
Ngui en profite pour hisser la voile
traditionnelle en feuilles de pandanus.
Hook, son frère, rapporte
quelques poissons pêchés au harpon.
C'est bientôt la fin de la journée.
Ngui et sa famille, profitent du vent,
pour mettre le cap sur
une autre île de l'archipel.
À quelques kilomètres de là.
À plusieurs centaines de kilomètres
de la Thaïlande, au Cambodge,
une autre communauté de nomades, les Chams,
passent leur vie sur le fleuve Mékong,
à bord de leur pirogue.
- Notre pirogue est aussi
importante que notre vie.
On survit grâce à elle.
En cette saison, il n'y a
pas beaucoup de poissons.
Ceux qu'on pêche,
nous permet juste de manger.
Pour une journée et une nuit de pêche,
on gagne entre 40 000 ou 50 000 riels.
La haute saison ne démarre que dans 2 mois.
Je relève le filet au bout de 30 minutes.
Il y a de tout.
Parfois, on trouve des petits
hoplites ou des poissons-chats.
On verra ce qu'on va trouver
dans le filet tout à l'heure.
La famille Yun a toujours
vécu à bord d'une pirogue.
En ce moment, il navigue
dans la région de Kampong Cham.
À la recherche des meilleures zones de pêche,
ces nomades du fleuve parcourent
des centaines de kilomètres par an.
Aujourd'hui, ils sont 4 à bord de la pirogue.
Moth et sa femme Saroch,
Solles, le fils de 25 ans,
et Mokmina, la petite dernière de 6 ans.
Les 2 filles aînées sont parties
travailler dans une usine de la capitale.
De nombreux jeunes cherchent
un emploi à terre.
Pour eux, la vie sur l'eau
est trop dure, trop dangereuse.
Le fleuve qui nourrit les hommes
peut aussi tout leur prendre.
- On avait aussi 2 autres filles,
elles sont mortes il y a longtemps.
C'étaient les aînées, les 2
plus jeunes sont à Phnom Penh.
- Elles étaient petites et se sont noyées.
La première est tombée de la pirogue
pendant que j'étais en train de réparer
les filets. Je n'avais rien entendu.
Pour la deuxième, une jeune fille
l'a mise au bord de l'eau sans la surveiller,
et la petite est tombée. On a mis du temps
pour la retrouver, mais c'était trop tard.
- Sur le fleuve, les pirogues
de l'ethnie des Chams,
ne se distinguent pas des
autres bateaux de pêche.
Ce matin, les Yun ont
capturé qu'un seul poisson.
Cette petite prise, qui n'a pas de valeur
marchande, sera parfaite pour le déjeuner.
- La plupart du temps, on mange du poisson.
Si on a assez d'argent et
que l'on est proche du marché,
on peut acheter des légumes.
Mais le plus souvent, c'est du
poisson avec de la sauce de poisson.
Donc la vaisselle, je la mets
là-bas, derrière le bac rose.
Et les vêtements, je les range là.
- Tout ce qui est encombrant, on le
place sous le plancher, dans la cale.
Et pour tout le reste,
c'est ici et là, sur la pirogue.
Le Mékong est un des plus
longs fleuves du monde.
Sur l'eau et sur les
berges, la vie se déploie.
- Au début de notre union,
on attendait la nuit pour faire nos besoins.
On était timide et maintenant,
elle se met à l'arrière de la pirogue,
je tourne la tête vers l'avant et ça va.
Et maintenant, je ne la dérange plus.
Bien que ce soit dur,
on est très unis, on s'aime.
J'aime ma femme, mes enfants
et les enfants nous aiment.
De retour chez les Moken en Thaïlande,
Ngui et sa famille arrivent
à destination de l'île de Ping.
C'est un bon coin pour les coquillages.
Chez les Moken, la cueillette
des crustacés est une affaire de femmes.
Dès l'enfance, Maniao a appris
à cuisiner ces fruits de mer.
- On les fait bouillir
plus ou moins longtemps,
on peut aussi les manger crus comme ça,
et les mélanger à d'autres aliments.
Les moken se déplacent en flottille.
Ainsi, plusieurs embarcations
naviguent de concert.
C'est agréable et plus sûr et on peut
compter sur la solidarité du groupe.
- On ne donne pas vraiment
de leçons de navigation.
Les garçons viennent
avec moi, ils m'observent,
et ils apprennent tout
simplement par eux-mêmes.
Cet après-midi, Ngui et ses compagnons
ont une mission essentielle,
à la survie de leur tribu,
trouver de l'eau potable.
Ngui connaît chacune des
précieuses sources de l'archipel.
- Je connais tous les
endroits d'approvisionnement
en eau potable de la région.
C'est mon père qui me les a montrés.
Quand j'étais jeune, il m'emmenait partout,
et c'est comme ça que j'ai connu
tous les sites d'eau fraîche.
Le Kabang est tout simplement
une maison sur les flots,
entourée d'un véritable terrain de jeu.
En fin de journée, le groupe
lève l'ancre à nouveau,
à la recherche d'un lieu
plus calme pour passer la nuit.
Cap sur la baie de Payam.
Ce soir, c'est Boon,
la vieille tante qui prépare le repas.
Au menu, poissons et coquillages.
- Je cuisine les moules et
les fruits de mer qu'on a récoltés.
Parfois, on y ajoute quelques épices.
Mais la mer n'est plus aussi
généreuse que dans ma jeunesse.
Parfois, on a même de la difficulté
à trouver du poisson.
Oui, on mange beaucoup de poisson.
Dans la baie de Payam,
les Moken ne sont pas seuls.
D'autres bateaux de pêche
entourent leur flottille.
Ces bateaux pratiquent une pêche intensive
à l'origine de la disparition des ressources.
Ils pillent le jardin des Moken
et menacent le mode de vie,
et l'existence même de ces nomades,
qui vivent en symbiose avec
la mer sacrée qui les nourrit.
La famille s'endort doucement,
bercé par la mer,
avec laquelle elle entretient
une relation spirituelle.
Retour au Cambodge.
Ce matin, la famille Yu part à la pêche.
Saroch, profite du trajet pour
ravauder leurs précieux filets.
- Je répare le filet au fur
et à mesure qu'il s'abîme.
Si on ne le fait pas régulièrement,
on ne pourra pas bien l'utiliser.
Pour jeter son filet dans le
fleuve, il faut une autorisation.
Comme les autres pêcheurs,
Moth a dû payer une redevance,
qui sert à embaucher les équipes,
qui nettoient le fleuve de
ces branches et détritus.
- À chaque saison,
on détermine le prix à payer.
Si la société chargée de l'entretien
du fleuve dépense 2 millions de riels,
elle divise la somme par le nombre
de pirogues dans le village,
et on paye 100 000
riels ou plus s'il le faut.
Après des heures de travail
ardues et sous un soleil de plomb,
la famille Yu pêche enfin un poisson qu'elle
pourra revendre demain matin au marché.
- C'est une bonne prise.
Un beau poisson comme ça,
on va pouvoir le vendre.
Non seulement ça va couvrir
les frais d'essence de la journée,
mais il restera de l'argent pour autre chose.
Ce poisson coûte au moins 50 000 riels.
Aujourd'hui, on a consommé trois litres
d'essence qui valent 10 000 riels.
Avec le reste, on va acheter du riz
et en donner à la petite pour l'école.
De retour à terre.,
Saroch rend visite à sa nièce, mère de 3
enfants et nomade du Mékong, comme elle.
- Je voudrais vous montrer
comment on protège les enfants,
pour éviter qu'ils ne tombent à l'eau
comme les miens. C'est important.
- Mon fils a un an et demi.
On a installé ce filet parce qu'on
a peur qu'il tombe dans l'eau.
Parfois, on attache son pied quand on dort.
J'ai peur qu'il tombe dans le
fleuve comme ceux de ma tante.
Je me sers de ce fil pour attacher
le pied du petit au toit de la pirogue,
quand il est très occupé
à jouer, il oublie le fil.
Parfois, il pleure pour qu'on l'enlève
car ça l'empêche de se déplacer.
Moth et Saroch pêchent près
du village de Kompong Cham,
là où est enterrée une de leurs filles.
- Je reste ici, car dans ma religion,
les femmes n'ont pas le droit
d'entrer dans le cimetière.
Je suis triste, ma fille me manque.
À chaque fois que je viens ici,
j'ai du mal à retenir mes larmes.
Quand je pense à elle,
je m'assois là et je pleure.
Mais les Cham ne restent pas
longtemps assis à pleurer.
Un mot les caractérise, la résilience.
Sous le régime sanguinaire de Pol Pot, une
grande partie de cette minorité musulmane,
a été exterminée par les Khmers rouges.
Malgré tout, ce peuple trouve la force de
continuer d'avancer, travailler et sourire.
Le jour se lève sur la mer d'Andaman.
Une fois par an, Jaoklatalé,
le père d'Engie accomplit un rituel.
Il demande à ses ancêtres de
protéger son kabang et sa famille.
Chez les Moken,
le bateau aussi, est un être
vivant dont il faut prendre soin.
- On prépare plusieurs offrandes,
de la nourriture, des gâteaux, de la liqueur,
de la poudre de rente pour
attirer les esprits féminins.
Ce sont eux qui nous protègent des tempêtes.
Et qui s'assurent que la mer
sera généreuse avec nous.
Ngui et sa famille naviguent
vers la baie de Ko Khao.
Un endroit symbolique qui rappelle
à tous l'incroyable puissance de l'océan.
En 2004, lorsque le tsunami
le plus meurtrier de tous les temps,
a frappé la côte thaïlandaise,
Ngui se trouvait ici,
sur le parcours de cette vague gigantesque.
Mais sa connaissance de la mer l'a sauvé.
- Il y a une histoire qui nous est racontée
par nos aînés de génération en génération,
et que tous les mokens connaissent.
C'est le récit du Laboon,
une énorme vague comme on n'en a jamais vu
et qui arrache tout sur son passage.
Les signes avant-coureurs sont,
le calme inhabituel de la mer,
l'apparition à la surface des poissons
qui vivent dans les profondeurs,
et la fuite des crabes de la plage
Si on remarque de tels bouleversements,
il n'y a qu'une seule consigne,
fuir sur une haute montagne.
Et c'est ce que nous avons fait.
La famille de Ngui et tous
les Moken ont survécu,
mais la plupart des bateaux ont été détruits.
Les Moken sont apatrides,
ils n'ont pas de papiers,
ils ne sont citoyens d'aucun pays
et depuis des millénaires,
leur seule patrie, c'est la mer.
- D'ici, on peut voir la Birmanie.
La frontière est à peu
près à 2 h de navigation.
La seule façon de m'identifier,
c'est avec mon bateau.
En ce qui me concerne,
c'est tout ce qu'on sait de moi.
Quand on voit mon kabang,
on sait que je suis moken.
Le peuple Moken sillonne la mer
d'Andaman, des 2 côtés de la frontière.
Au Myanmar et en Thaïlande.
Les nomades de l'eau sont libres de
circuler dans l'immensité de l'océan.
Au Cambodge, la famille Yu,
met le pied sur la terre ferme.
Ce matin, Saroch se rend au marché pour
y vendre sa belle prise de la veille.
- Je suis contente,
j'en ai tiré 80 000 riels.
Avec cet argent, je vais acheter
du riz et de l'essence pour la pirogue.
J'ai acheté pour 1 000 riels
de concombre, une pastèque,
et un demi kilo de patates douces.
J'aimerais bien acheter des bonnes
choses comme de la viande et des vêtements,
mais je n'ai pas le budget pour ça.
J'attends quand j'en aurai plus.
La viande de bœuf coûte très cher.
J'en achète que lorsqu'on
a beaucoup d'argent.
On mange plutôt les poissons qu'on a pêché.
J'aimerais bien attraper
encore des poissons comme celui-là.
Motivé, confiant et certain que
le fleuve sera à nouveau généreux,
la famille repart pêcher.
Mais le vent se lève brusquement.
Une tempête est peut-être à prévoir.
Sur le Mékong, elles sont
aussi soudaine que redoutable.
- On a rencontré cette
situation plusieurs fois.
Pour éviter que la pirogue
ne coule, je sautais dans l'eau.
- Lors d'une tempête,
les vagues étaient très grosses,
et comme notre pirogue était toute
petite, elle a coulé près de la berge.
J'avais tellement peur que je serrais
mes enfants contre moi et je pleurais.
Il est 15 h.
La famille Yu délaisse son filet
de pêche et se prépare pour la prière.
- Avant de faire la prière, il faut
que j'enlève tout ce qui est impur,
donc tout ce qui est impropre.
C'est pour ça que j'enlève mes habits
et que je mets des vêtements blancs.
- Dans ma religion, la prière est
accompagnée de gestes d'inclination,
de génuflexions, de prosternations.
Et durant la prière,
on répète ces mouvements 4 fois.
Si, par exemple, le ciel devient noir,
et qu'il commence à y avoir beaucoup de vent,
et qu'on n'est qu'au 2ᵉ
mouvement de la prière,
on doit continuer les 2 autres,
on ne doit pas interrompre la prière.
Et c'est seulement une fois qu'on a
terminé la prière qu'on peut se sauver.
On dit que si on interrompt la prière,
cela constitue un péché.
Solles travaille parfois avec ses parents,
mais comme de nombreux jeunes Chams,
il ne veut plus de cette vie dangereuse
et difficile de pêcheur nomade.
- Je ne veux plus vivre sur la pirogue et
j'aimerais sortir mes parents de cette vie.
Quand j'aurai les moyens plus tard,
j'emmènerai mes parents
vivre sur la terre ferme.
Je ne veux plus qu'ils vivent
ce quotidien difficile.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
je travaille dans une menuiserie,
j'espère un jour, avoir mon affaire.
Si je réussis, mes parents
auront une vie meilleure.
La petite dernière va à
l'école sur la terre ferme,
et bientôt il n'y aura plus que Moth
et Saroch à bord de la pirogue.
Sur la mer d'Andaman, nous
retrouvons Ngui et sa famille.
Son Kabang est le tout dernier exemplaire
de la pirogue traditionnelle des Moken.
La quasi-totalité de leurs bateaux ayant
disparu lors du tsunami de 2004,
ils ne peuvent en construire de nouveaux.
Les lois environnementales thaïlandaises,
interdisent désormais de couper le bois
rare nécessaire à leur fabrication.
Si le père de famille perd
sa maison sur les flots,
c'est 4 000 ans d'histoire humaine
qui couleront avec elle.
- Notre culture est de tradition
orale, on n'a pas d'écrit.
Donc, la façon de construire le kabang
traditionnel va se perdre.
Auparavant, les jeunes apprenaient
les techniques de construction navale,
en les pratiquant, mais on en construit plus.
Alors désormais, comment ce
savoir va-t-il se transmettre ?
La plupart des Moken qui n'ont
pas reconstruit de Kabang,
utilisent des bateaux très courants
en Thaïlande, les bateaux à longue queue.
- D'autres familles de Moken,
qui ont perdu leur bateau,
se retrouvent sur l'île de Koh Payam.
La majorité des nomades des mers,
est aujourd'hui sédentarisée
dans  des villages de ce type,
et certains vivent dans une pauvreté extrême.
Depuis toujours, les Moken vivent
sur Terre quelques semaines par an.
Durant la mousson du sud-ouest,
quand la mer est agitée et imprévisible,
et les nomades ont pris l'habitude de
s'installer dans des huttes temporaires.
Aujourd'hui, ces abris temporaires sont
parfois devenus leur résidence principale.
- C'est très difficile de
vivre dans ce village,
parce que le niveau de
la mer monte sans cesse.
Les Moken ne peuvent aller vivre ailleurs.
Maintenant, toutes les îles
appartiennent à des sociétés privées.
Notre peuple qui se déplaçait
d'une île à l'autre auparavant,
est désormais confiné dans
des endroits assez hostiles.
Aujourd'hui, la famille de Ngui
va rendre visite aux 2 filles aînées
qui font leurs études à
Nam Ken, au nord de Koh Lak.
Les filles de Ngui ne veulent
plus vivre en mer,
et s'éloignent du mode de
vie traditionnel des Moken.
D'ailleurs, elles s'adressent
à leur père en thaï,
et ne pratiquent plus la langue Moken.
- Je leur parle en thaï parce que
nous sommes sur la terre ferme,
et ici, la langue d'usage, c'est le thaï.
- Je ne suis pas allé à l'école, mais je suis
contente que mes filles puissent y aller,
quand j'ai des ennuis de santé,
elles peuvent m'aider,
car je ne parle pas thaï comme un Ngui.
- Je veux rester en ville,
car je veux finir mes études
et avoir un bon travail.
Ainsi, je pourrais aider
ma famille dans le futur.
Si je pouvais devenir médecin,
j'en serais très heureuse.
Je resterai sur la terre ferme et les Moken
pourraient venir se faire soigner par moi.
Les Moken sont partis
de Chine il y a 4 000 ans.
Ils ont survécu à tous les dangers de la
mer, même le Laboon, le terrible tsunami.
Aujourd'hui, le mode de vie
et les connaissances millénaires
des hommes poissons,
sont en train de disparaître.
Il ne resterait plus que 2 000 à 3 000 moken.
Malgré tout, ces nomades des mers
ne sont pas préoccupés par le futur.
D'ailleurs, dans leur langue,
il n'existe pas de mot pour inquiétude.
- On ne sait rien à propos de l'avenir.
On ne fait que vivre ce qui
se passe ici et maintenant.
Si quelque chose doit arriver,
ça arrivera, c'est tout.
Mais on veut rester sur
la mer, dans nos bateaux.
C'est notre vie.
On veut continuer à manger du poisson, des
fruits de mer et se faire bercer par l'eau.
C'est ce que souhaitent tous les moken.
- J'aimerais aussi pouvoir vivre
sur un bateau, avoir une famille.
Je pourrais voyager et manger
du poisson toute ma vie.
- Le peuple Moken est fait pour vivre sur
un bateau et voyager comme des hommes libres.
Au Cambodge, dans ce village,
à quelques kilomètres de Kampong Cham,
plusieurs familles Cham ont
réussi à s'acheter un petit terrain.
Moth et son clan font souvent escale ici.
Ailleurs, les Cham ne sont
pas forcément les bienvenus.
Ils perdent peu à peu
leur liberté de mouvement.
- À Kampong Cham, on n'a pas ce problème-là.
Mais à Phnom Penh, on ne peut plus
accoster sur n'importe quelle rive.
Par exemple, on ne peut plus se mettre devant
le Palais royal et plein d'autres endroits,
qui ont été privatisés.
À peine, on accoste sur ces rives,
on se fait dégager immédiatement.
Et parfois, on ne peut même
pas s'approcher des berges.
Les Cham voient ainsi leur
fragile équilibre menacé,
et le fleuve est de moins
en moins généreux en poissons.
- Pour ce qui est de la pêche,
il y a une grosse différence.
Avant, on prenait 5 kilos de
poisson par jour dans nos filets,
maintenant, on ne prend plus qu'un kilo.
En fin de journée, le couple rend
visite aux parents de Saroch.
- Nous aussi, on était des pêcheurs.
- On a vécu de la pêche dès notre enfance.
- On vivait sur l'eau comme eux.
- Une fois mariée,
on a continué cette activité.
Autrefois, il y avait beaucoup de poissons.
On pouvait gagner relativement
bien notre vie avec la pêche.
On a mis beaucoup de temps
avant d'acquérir notre maison.
Saroch avait une dizaine d'années.
On a eu 13 enfants et on vivait
tous ensemble sur la pirogue.
- On est issus tous les
2 d'une famille pauvre.
On n'avait pas d'argent pour avoir ne
serait-ce qu'un petit commerce à nous.
Après notre mariage, en complément
des emprunts que nous avons faits,
mes parents nous ont aidés pour
qu'on puisse acheter une pirogue,
et pour avoir des filets, on a fait
crédit auprès des commerçants chinois.
C'est vrai qu'il y a de la place chez mes
parents, mais il n'y a pas de travail.
J'aimerais changer de vie,
quitter la pirogue et le fleuve,
mais sans argent, c'est compliqué.
À l'aube de la cinquantaine, Moth arpente
ce terrain qu'il rêve de pouvoir s'acheter.
Un endroit où sa femme
et lui pourront vieillir.
- J'aimerais posséder ce terrain
pour y construire une maison.
À mon âge, je ne pense pas que j'aurai
un jour les moyens de l'acheter,
même en travaillant le restant de ma vie.
La pêche ne rapporte plus assez.
Il y a de moins en moins de poissons,
je ne pourrais pas gagner assez d'argent.
C'est la vie, je fais avec, mais je serai
aux anges si on m'offrait ce terrain.
Je serais vraiment heureux.
Tout en continuant de rêver,
le couple retourne à sa pirogue.
Le petit nid flottant où ils s'aiment depuis
30 ans et où ils ont conçu leurs 6 enfants.
Le Mékong demeure encore et
toujours leur principal allié.
Un fleuve majestueux qui les
a vu naître, les accueille,
et les nourrit depuis qu'ils sont au monde.
- On s'entend bien avec ma femme et
les enfants ne font pas de problème.
Donc, je peux dire que je suis heureux.
On galère, mais ce n'est pas grave,
on a la force pour continuer d'avancer.
Les Cham du Cambodge,
les Moken de la Thaïlande,
2 peuples qui ont l'eau comme
pays et le bateau comme foyer.
Les derniers des nomades au mode
de vie d'un autre temps.